[Applause]
the Olympics today we're doing the
Olympics greek-style and not like
current Greek but old Greek the Olympics
are an amazing global competition of
basically everything i'm terrible.i i
love the Olympics because it's just like
war but no one actually dies we're here
at the getty villa which is one of the
largest collections of Greek and Roman
antiquity to learn from an education
specialist in archeology all about the
ancient Olympics the Olympics are called
the Olympics because there at Olympia so
that's the place they started in 776 BC
and they lasted over a thousand years
I'm not good at sports but I do like
mythology I can appreciate the studious
side of the Olympic Games is probably
symbolic of getting fit for war
activities and it's also just because
you're honoring gods I just assumed that
they were kind of like our games today
just with way more white people as long
as you were a Greek you could come from
anywhere in the Mediterranean and come
to the games we were representing your
city-state your city-state just as we
are was very excited about your
competition today I'm representing the
great state of Nemea which is where Zeus
is from king of the gods I'm
representing the great city of Athens
because it's the most New York and we
assume that Athens were like the Jews of
Greece I will be representing the
city-state of Corinth which of course is
related to Poseidon and we all know I
have a great history with the ocean oh
I'll be representing the city-state of
Delphi because they just have lots of
temples and they do weird in them
I love or on how are they different from
the modern Olympics no women are allowed
in the Olympics and there's no really
good fabric so naked is good who do you
think is gonna win well you have to take
your clothes off first
[Music]
may boil up before the events to protect
themselves from Sun officiate we need
our oil yeah thank you sorry Katie what
do i splash it rub it on yourselves oh
it's so much thicker than you think
care for though everyone's naked they're
oily they're dirty and there's no women
allowed right sounds like our kind of
party get that fanny
no Keith you've got a great fight yeah
you actually have artifacts here at the
Getty bill that they picked up some of
these events yes so this would be a
men's category Victor and there are no
weight classes so you could go up
against anybody who's not circumcised
the sign of being a barbarian that you
circumcised your penis and sometimes
athletes tie their penises she said that
you had to tie your string to your
foreskin I'm out I'm not - I'm no
comment that's a job for Keith in a
lovely dress yeah you look great she
said tie it like a water balloon there's
not a lot - it's pretty shrunken because
of the pressure I'll be honest it's like
you put a leash on a snake yeah well
your snakes are gonna get away mine's
gonna stay put if you have worked to be
worthy of going to Olympia I love
winning I'm all of my life after
Hercules Hercules killed his wife and
kids you've done nothing indolent or
base I'm not above cheating so I yeah
I'm just gonna probably cheat my way
through this if you have trained
properly for ten straight months
Oh forth with a good and positive
attitude to Olympia about ten straight
minutes everyone who competes in the
Olympics whether it be in ancient times
or this year in Brazil we're gonna see
the same thing happen which is the best
of the best going head-to-head and today
you're gonna see the exact opposite of
that no one else jobs you guys how to
drop it some dirt whoa Eugene we got it
one of the events will be recreating
today you'll do three events of the
pentathlon the long jump the discus and
wrestling but the foot race is the most
important if you want your name on the
Olympiad you have to win the foot race
long jump is extremely weird very
different from today you use weights
probably you ran about ten meters you
launched off on one foot went up in the
air and went to a ball and landed like a
gymnast so that your footprints show in
the dirt and we're naked and you're
naked Oh corns big car that's uppity
[Music]
let's go for two I didn't do a great job
I'm gonna jump further
what's my team again Goran Praetorian
copy tag it was an inch further an inch
further check horns use the momentum
from the weights to guide you forward
three to five pounds has been shown in
modern experiments to actually increase
the distance you can jump oh wow so if
you fall over if there's a big but
markup on the ground it doesn't count a
[ __ ] but on the corral
I'll take a minute look at a Eugene's
ass all right
that's funny all right one for the lady
I'll be tech
[Music]
Wow
a BTech it counts the words back foot
like stop I know there's a lot of
flights this is this is it's fertilizer
yeah you jumping in sand like today
right you're jumping in dirt I bet a
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
some of the names of officials include
words that indicate that they can hit
you and then incidentally people comment
about the kinds of things you might get
flogged for harder to be flogged yes and
cheating is big so if you cheat you
could get flogged if you false start you
can get flogged right there in front of
everybody my name is Ned Fullmer Nemea
State University I'll be tech ran
straight through come on round two a
Pete a there's a dog oh don't be it
smells like so he's gonna RP here
determination stocks in the mind and
games in the name how its led the memory
for that don't know I beat a yeah
there's dirt on the button what right
where you approve
and the winner for the long jump is the
Olympian from Dolphin so I don't even
get a medal it's just no you just got a
pop you may have a palm of victory as
you win your individual event well at
Olympia you literally win an olive
wreath and some ribbons tied around you
but no money ribbon next is we will be
throwing the discus you start and pull
back your arm get a big swing and go up
high and let loose and never actually
twist around very much and modern discus
throwers when interviewed are pretty
horrified at the possibility of missing
out on all that good rotation that's
just like tossing a frisbee not even the
olive oil makes this especially hard to
hold it is sort of like our discus in
art often it's bigger how do you think
he did
let's discus we can know I went to the
science so we did not mark it
you got a knot step over the ondraw
[Music]
you cheat you can't be Olimpia nice it's
a nice toss
are you not into change then right like
a frisbee no
[Music]
better than that first try boom now that
I'm like doing well I kind of try it
okay give me a little pad for good luck
the Greeks do care a lot about form so
you probably want to look beautiful are
you doing on the let's go which means on
the furthest to throw everybody knows
corns hurt my arm to do I'll tell you
what now it's not easy on my wrist
[Music]
thirty six feet and the winner of the
discus is Eugene and the losers come on
but we're going to wrestle for glory
wrestling you have some rules you're not
supposed to I go you're not supposed to
bite and you are supposed to use finesse
and elegance in your throwing so it's
more like wrestling today than the other
event I'm gonna be wrestling Eugene the
me and Zack are gonna hug and roll
around it's you start standing and very
often you put your foreheads together in
a sort of RAM position and then your job
is to up and your opponent and get his
back shoulder or hip in the dust where
you can see the mark on his oily body
[Applause]
it's hard to grab he's covered in oil
glory don't hurt each other happy take
[Music]
[Music]
ours we're happy take how do we know all
this well if you're an archaeologist
it's infuriating because we don't know a
lot there's a thousand years of
information most of it's missing so we
have to find weird things that give us
information it's incredibly fun to come
up with the scenarios for how it might
have worked and wait for somebody to
uncover some more evidence he has a very
large but it weighs him down round three
each holds a point so this round will
determine the winner if we both lose at
the same time with your time it's your
fight for Greece we were just trying to
tie
I just I just fit good match guys are
idiots and the winner of the wrestling
event of the pentathlon is the Olympian
from Nemea this is for my wife and all
the people in the great state of new
media but you team did win the
pentathlon doesn't matter because it all
comes down to the race yeah that's poop
on his face so I kind of think he's
still the loser
[Music]
being the fastest is what counts but
they're not timing them you have your
left foot forward your right foot back
you lean forward but you don't go down
so low as we do today to push off we
know that sometimes there were ropes
that were let down so that you couldn't
start too soon are the only pins ready
yeah ready if you win the foot race in
Olympia the entire calendars based on
you so you get to do a photo shoot in
the calendar they don't have that but
they know your name
Zac and I won't do so hot today that's
my biggest competition
that's right Eugene I'm coming for you
baby Hercules Hercules is that this
Hercules is not killing his wife three
two one a beating
we're reconstructing the Olympic both
taken on the first day you have in your
hands the flesh of a boar there's a
sacrifice on an altar to Zeus I swear on
the flesh of this wild sacrifice to Zeus
[Music]
do nothing
you can't put words in the middle of a
note Zach you're holding a sacred bore
believe that for a goddamn second I
think that we're in big trouble
ah I beat you geez glory eternal glory
well at least for four years
Congrats a man on his victory the rest
of Zach and I are technically tying with
Eugene this is boof and if you work hard
you could be an Olympian too
[Music]
if we were celebrating a succession of
Olympics that had never ended this would
be the 698 Olympiad near the end of the
four years so eugene son of jay please
climb on to the podium the goddess of
victory nikkei is with you eugene of
Delphine's holding the palm you are the
victor and the many skills of the
pentathlon having overcome in long jump
discus and wrestling we crown you with a
wreath of olives I kind of wish Olympics
feature in these sports today I mean who
wouldn't want to watch a bunch of naked
people rolling around in dirt Ned of
Nemea son of James climb on the podium
please in this one hundred and tenth
Olympiad holding the palm for the
victory of the Stadion
because of your swiftness your name will
be associated with this Olympiad for all
time mentioned a calendar well you serve
as the name of the calendar you would be
on it in honor of Zeus
you are now awarded the Oliver II the
fact that we are naked just gave us this
sense of purity like uses your body and
your mind and your determination I
noticed they haven't risen to keep an
eye get ribbon no because you're losers
I can't get my back you mind
you know I have a lottery I didn't like
the Olympics coming in now I think
they're pretty cool you don't like the
Olympics because I smell and feel
terrible I've learned so much about
manure oil and all four of you
really
so sorry this is what most try guys
shoots are like
in honor of Greece obviously this is the
Greece that was on us we have saved all
of our goop and have brought it here for
you to judge sometimes they save the
material the oil the sweat the dirt and
put it in a container and the gymnasium
they practice in can even sell it I'm
thinking that one's pretty clean and the
goose belongs to thank you so much us on
the accuracy of our attempt to
recreating the Grecian Olympics until
next time I lost everything
[Music]